last question today is from Gianna
Gianna says would you rather go a week
without your phone or a week without
your toothbrush uh I I think that I have
a pretty clear answer on this uh I don't
know okay if I don't have my phone I can
still email on a computer uh I can't
really text people so maybe my social
life that week would be negatively
impacted I don't actually make that many
calls most of the calls I get are
telemarketers so I think I could go a
week without the phone as long as I
wasn't traveling where I need my my
google maps constantly to find my way to
where I'm going I think I could go the
week without the phone okay we just have
a little bit of an impact on my social
life but maybe i would use facebook
messages to make plans week without a
toothbrush at face value that's pretty
bad right if you don't brush your teeth
for a week that's gotta be a disaster
however for a week if you still are
given access to toothpaste and you can
put the toothpaste on your finger and
rub it on your teeth it's not like
brushing your teeth but it's also not
bad i mean i think i could get through a
week by just rubbing toothpaste on my
teeth so if i had to choose I don't know
III guess I choose the week without the
toothbrush because it seems relatively
straightforward to still keep my teeth
kind of clean I also still have my
fluoride rinse and I'd be able to floss
so I i think i would do okay you know
yeah there's ways around both of these
and i think i would agree i would go
with the toothbrush I could definitely
just put some toothpaste on my finger
and kind of brush using that the
mouthwash floss it should be fine now if
the question was rewritten as would you
rather go a week without your phone or a
week without cleaning your teeth in any
way meaning no floss no using your
finger whatever I think then my answer
is totally different i'm definitely
going without the phone for a week we
can also change the question to so that
you can use any mobile devices no
tablets maybe not your computer no
internet and at that point i'd probably
go back to the two i would keep the
phone yeah i mean i wouldn't be able to
we wouldn't be able to do the show right
if we if it was no internet nor
electronics of any kind uh i mean to to
what extent there are many people who
just wouldn't be able to work
if that was the way the question was
phrased that that would be a different
story altogether okay very good
questions this week drastically
different one very serious about
pseudoscience one serious but more
lighthearted about records in sports and
then one that's just sort of like a what
would you rather which uh hey you know
every once in a while a good what would
you rat what would you rather isn't bad
on today's bonus show Florida gas
stations are testing a pizza vending
machine a major hurricane uh is enroute
to the United States and number three
droids are plentiful at a tokyo tech
fair and I'm going to tell you a little
bit about that david pakman.com slash
membership is how you sign up and get
instant access to the bonus show speak
to you then